today on the matt wall show as the
backlash against the child sexualizing
cuties movie on netflix grows it's
important for us to take a step back and
understand
that the movie fits into a larger and
diabolical trend in our culture which
we'll talk about today also five
headlines including
an interesting um expose on the
privileged lives of some of the rioters
arrested in new york
and in our daily cancellation i'll
address the media outrage about fans
in kansas city last night who allegedly
booed racial unity
that's not really what they were doing
but we'll talk about that today all that
on the way first
a word from policy genius you know
something we don't always think about
but we should we don't like to think
about it because the fact is
uh we aren't going to be around forever
and anything can happen
and that's why i have life insurance
it's about protecting my family
in light of the unknown and the
inevitable that's the way that i look at
it september is national life insurance
awareness month
but with everything going on right now a
lot of people aren't even aware that
it's possible to buy life insurance at
all the good news is that it's still
easy to shop for life insurance right
now it's as easy as as it's ever been
because of policy genius and if you have
loved ones depending on your income you
probably should here's the main thing
here's the main thing to keep in mind
right now
you could save fifty hundred dollars or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare
life insurance policies when you're
shopping for a policy that could last
for a decade or more
those savings really start to add up
what is policy genius well it's an
insurance marketplace built and backed
by a team of industry experts
let's quickly uh talk about how it works
okay very very very simple step step one
head to policygenius.com in minutes you
can work out how much coverage you need
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price step two
you apply for your lowest price and then
step three the policy genius team will
take it from there handle all the
paperwork all of the red tape
so really it's two steps for you and
then everything else is policy genius
super easy very painless that's been my
experience with a policy genius
and uh you don't you know you don't have
to know what the hell you're doing in
order to use policy genius which is good
for me because i never do know what the
hell i'm doing
so um if you need life insurance head to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could say fifteen hundred
hundred hundred dollars or more a year
by comparing quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right
okay well you know before the
coronavirus lockdowns forced a temporary
hiatus from these sorts of activities
libraries across the country on any
given night
might have featured cross-dressing men
with sexually suggestive stage names
reading stories to large crowds of
visibly confused children
a scene such as this could be found in
both red and blue states big cities and
small towns
sometimes against the objections of a
minority of residents sometimes with
near unanimous approval if the drag
queen story hour was held in a more
radically liberal area it may have come
with a warm-up act like a striptease
by the uh by the drag queen or there may
have been an opportunity for the
children to lay on top of the drag queen
and
wrestle with him these are both
documented occurrences at drag queen
story hours
if the event was held in houston the
drag queen may have also been a
registered sex offender
shock of all shocks now these sorts of
spectacles are so common these days that
they become old news
some people still protest thankfully but
drag queen story hour is officially
a thing in our culture and it's here to
stay
of course nobody's ever been able to
sufficiently explain
why it needs to be a thing why exactly
do we need cross-dressing burlesque
performers at the library why can't the
librarian come and read like a dr seuss
book to the kids
as had been the custom for decades
before we decided that the job would be
better done by men dressed like satanic
sexualized nuns
if we are given any coherent answer at
all to this question
it'll be some pablum about tolerance
acceptance and so forth but the real
answer the one they won't say out loud
is that the left has found public
libraries to be yet another useful
staging ground for the sexual
indoctrination of children
there are many such staging grounds
public schools have proven of course to
be especially fertile
soil for this comprehensive sex
education in schools all over the
country and in europe
goes far beyond teaching the scientific
facts of human sexuality children are
told
not just what sex is but given advice on
how
and when and in what way to engage in it
a sex ed curriculum recently unveiled in
california for example
gives students tips on how to perform
oral sex bondage
the world health the world health
organization has issued its own guidance
on approaching sex ed
recommending that children as young as
four as young as four be given
information about and i quote
enjoyment and pleasure when touching
one's own body
a sex ed program called teen talk which
originated in canada but has been since
adopted
uh in some places in the u.s advises
kids that among other things
quoting now from their website anal sex
is safe and can be done with a penis
finger or sex toy
it also goes into issues or you know of
so-called gender identity claiming that
some people are quote
beyond male or female or maybe a
combination of both male and female
speaking of which the radical gender
ideology being pushed in our kids
through media hollywood government in
schools etc
represents perhaps the most insidious
and damaging form of sexual uh childhood
sexualization
we are now told that children before
they're old enough to enter kindergarten
are mentally and emotionally competent
enough
to choose their own gender by nine or
ten if not earlier we're told that they
can
meaningfully consent to taking hormone
pills that will radically alter their
body's normal processes
in some cases minors are allowed to
consent to permanent surgical mutilation
breast removal and other abominations
this clearly has the effect of
sexualizing children as it normalizes
the idea that kids are emotionally and
psychologically capable
of giving consent as i have argued many
times the whole entire basis for our
laws against sexual contact between
adults and children is that children
cannot consent to such contact and thus
if the contact is made it is always
equal to assault
no matter what the child says about it
as the left pushes for gender changes
among children
they also undermine the fundamental
basis for age of consent laws
and there is no reason to think that
they don't know what they're doing
when they do that now we could go on for
many more examples of the sexualization
of children
and the normalization of pedophilia in
our culture we could talk about 11 year
old drag queens performing at gay clubs
we could talk about
the fact that children on average are
exposed to hardcore pornography at the
age of 10 or 11 if not younger
and that sites like pornhub explicitly
market
to minors and make millions of dollars
doing so we can talk simply about
the music and movies and shows and
everything else that are produced on a
mainstream level
and marketed to young audiences that are
hyper sexual
this is all part of the same effort and
this is all
the context into which the netflix movie
cuties fits we discussed it yesterday
i'm not going to get into the graphic
details again about the the movie i'm
sure you've heard it all
by now uh you've heard more than you
probably want to hear
but the point i want to emphasize today
is that we shouldn't be shocked
that the movie exists and that it's
being defended so desperately
speaking of desperate defenses here's
perhaps the most absurd one that i've
yet seen
this is from aja romano a vox film
critic so you know it's going to be good
aja says
incidentally i'm a critic who highly
recommends netflix's cuties is a
wonderful poignant challenging and
nuanced coming-of-age tale
smartly crafted by a wonderful director
the controversy surrounding it seems to
be propaganda fueled by q
anon types and anti-semites i also feel
like
you couldn't have picked a better film
to frame such a controversy around i'm
frankly delighted by a bunch of bigots
settling in with pitchforks to flame the
pedophile movie and discovering this
lovely subtle story about girls battling
fraught gender roles
yes objecting to a film that shows
scantily clad 11 year old muslims
simulating sex acts is
anti-semitism yes
it appears that aja reached into the
grab bag of isms and pulled one out
randomly which you can't blame her i
suppose there's no coherent way to make
an argument
that people who don't approve of movies
about twerking children are bigots
so that leaves you only with incoherent
arguments like this one
or you could simply admit that the movie
is highly inappropriate
and offensive because that is
self-evidently the case but aja can't do
that
many in the media can't do that netflix
could do it netflix issued
another statement yesterday yet again
defending the film
uh this is a statement from netflix
saying uh quote cuties is a social
commentary against the sec
against the sexualization of young
children it's an award-winning film and
powerful story
about the pressure young girls face on
social media and from society
more generally growing up and we'd
encourage anyone who cares about these
important issues to watch the movie
you know that would be great if it were
true
a commentary on the sexualization of
young children
would be very worthwhile and important
but netflix can't explain
why that commentary would include crotch
shots of 11 year olds
they can't explain why the commentary
about the bad thing
must must actually exhibit the bad thing
the director of the film has never been
able to explain that either in fact
she did an interview with the rap at
sundance back in the early part of the
year way before there was this
controversy
and in that interview while explaining
her motivation for making the movie
she never really says that the movie is
a critique of childhood sexualization
the interviewer leads her there the
interviewer herself says that she
thought
the movie was critical of the
hypersexualization of western culture
but here's what the director had to say
in her own words about
why she made the movie the question is
should we have the right
to choose which women we can
be in this world um
in our culture you know even today
me i can say i'm not totally free
because i love to to wear
short dresses and at the same time
sometimes
when i go to the religious ceremony i
i wear the veil as well so just shoes
as a woman who
who do you want to to be okay so
according to her
she was exploring a woman's struggle to
be free and to make choices for herself
uh though the characters in the film are
not women they are children
nonetheless the theme is she explains it
there back when she was
getting only accolades for the movie
because only degenerate film critics had
seen it
the theme as she explained it uh was
kind of different than what we're being
told now
and i think that gets much closer to the
real motivation behind the making of the
movie
and it gets to the heart of the
motivation for the sexualization of
children in general in our culture for
the left
for the left the highest good is to be
is to enable people to make
unfettered choices choices specifically
in the realm of sexuality and gender
they aren't as much fans of choices in
other areas of life of course but
in the realm of sexuality and gender
people must be able to make choices
without regard to any boundaries at all
even biological and scientific
boundaries must be discarded
moral boundaries must be discarded
certainly religious boundaries must be
torn down
that's what the movie seems to really be
about that's what the sexualization of
children in our culture is
largely about the goal is to destroy
moral boundaries and to view
people as primarily sexual beings
regardless of age or anything else
the point always and ultimately is about
the denial of objective truth and
objective morality and the establishment
of a society
where everything is relative and and and
what is good what is most good is for
people to simply do what they want in
the moment
and this netflix movie is just one more
salvo in that war but it's a war that is
ongoing and has been going on for a long
time
and will continue uh even after this
controversy fades let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know when you get on the internet uh
you you leave yourself wide open to the
bad guys who are out there not to be
paranoid but there are a lot of bad guys
out there on the internet who want to
steal your information how much do you
think your personal information is worth
to
cyber criminals well researchers have
compiled an overview of the average
price of stolen
personal data for sale in the dark web
and
while online banking logins cost an
average of 35 bucks the range of
documents and account details
needed to commit identity theft cost you
know over twelve hundred dollars
so that's a lot of money they stand to
make by stealing your information and
selling it on the dark web
um and you know and then it becomes even
more
fraught when you consider kids on the
internet
and all the ways that they are
vulnerable and exposed
and that's why it's so important to get
lifelock and it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives
you could miss certain identity threats
by just monitoring your credit
um because you're not you're not looking
at what's going on in the dark web good
thing there's lifelock lifelock detects
a wide range of identity threats
um stuff that you wouldn't be able to
find on yourself and if they detect your
information has potentially been
compromised
they're going to send you an alert and
they're not going to leave you in the
lurch they're going to have identity
theft restoration specialists who are
there
to help you get it all sorted out no one
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions all businesses
but you can find out if your information
is on
is on the dark web get your free dark
web scan at lifelock.com
scan pick the plan that's right for you
and save 25 off
your first year with promo code walsh
that's a free scan at lifelock.com
scan and 20 five percent off with promo
code
walsh all right number one today of
course is the 19th anniversary of
11 a good time to pray for our country
there's never a bad time never a bad day
or bad time but today
in particular is good for that um i
don't have much commentary to offer on 9
11 19 years out except to wonder aloud
to ask the same question i guess that so
many people
ask as these anniversaries roll around
and that is if there was another 911
i mean a real another 911 you know
things are always
claimed to be the next 911 or the new
911 or another 911
but i'm talking about something that
that really matches that
in terms of the magnitude and something
that uh weighs on the national
consciousness in the same way
to the same extent if that happened
again
when it happens again would we be
capable as a nation
of unifying even briefly
in the face of it as everyone always
those of us who lived through it
um i was i don't know 13 or 14 i think
what 9 11 happened and um those of us
who lifted we talk all the time about
how
the nation seemed unified in the direct
aftermath
of of the the terrorist attack i think i
think we probably overstate just how
unified we probably
in our minds emotionally overstate and
exaggerate it
um especially those of us who were kids
when it happened
you know but there's no question that
there was a real sense of unity it
didn't last for very long but it was
there
and i you wonder could could we if there
was a 911 like tomorrow
would there be even one day of everybody
on the same side or would it be
boom immediately we're politicizing it
blaming each other putting fingers and
everything
that's the question i'm not going to get
much into my answer because my answer is
very depressing
my answer is basically no but let's not
harp on that today
let's move on number two biden spokesman
tj ducklow who perhaps
more than anyone else in politics looks
like his name
appeared on fox yesterday and became
very evasive and seemingly flummoxed
over extremely
basic questions about the candidate and
his positions
uh listen to this says joe biden ever
used a teleprompter during local
interviews
or to answer q a with supporters brett
we are not going to engage this is
this is straight from the trump campaign
exactly they're using it and what it
does
and what it does brett is it's trying to
distract the american people i'm just
they're using it they talk about it
every day can you say yes or no that's
because they talk about it every day
brad because they don't have
a coherence well you have an answer yes
or no
brett they talk about it every day
because they don't have a coherent
argument for why donald
trump deserves re-election deserves four
more years we know that he lied to the
american people we know that he has not
uh shown leadership during this crisis
and they are desperate to throw anything
they can against the wall
to try to distract from that fact i
understand but you can't answer the
question
right i am not going to allow a trump
campaign to funnel their questions
through fox news and get me to respond
to that well tj we appreciate your time
and thank you for coming on
thanks brett i love the tone he takes
when he's asked a very basic question
so it's like tj is the sun hot
now brett brett now brett brett now
brett
right that's a republican talking point
no i just want to know if the sun is hot
brett now hey brett come on brett
that's you got to stop with the gotcha
questions but really
this is a reflection i think of the fact
that tj ducklow and friends
um and by the way ducklow and friends
should be the name of a children's show
on
nick jr but ducklow and friends they
spend most of their time
in the cnn msnbc left-wing media orbit
and are simply never asked any
challenging questions
at all of any kind on the rare occasion
that they get a real question they are
permitted to dodge it with one little
move
and then and then the interviewer's
gonna move on he's not gonna he's not
gonna press the issue
uh and so they're simply unprepared for
any kind of real real questioning and
these were really really basic
uh good questions a question like okay
what would you have actually done
differently you can criticize
trump's response to the chronovirus what
would you have actually done that he
didn't do
doesn't want to answer that question
number three speaking of uh speaking of
msnbc and uh people on there nancy
pelosi was on msnbc yesterday and
here's how that went we have these fires
in california
and in the west of 16 people have died
in washington
oregon and california including a
firefighter and a one-year-old baby
we our firefighters have been so very
very courageous
now we're again breaking records mother
earth is angry she's
telling us whether she's telling us with
hurricanes on the gulf coast
fires in the west whatever it is that
the climate crisis
is real and has an impact and of course
we can assume
no follow-up on that either no question
like speaker pelosi
how long have you been a pagan can you
tell us more about your paganism
that'd be a good question because the
idea that mother earth
is angry angry at us and is now creating
hurricanes and fires to punish us
is pure paganism it's a perfect example
of the kind of thing they can get away
with saying on msnbc
without any follow-up mother earth is
angry at us and is creating fires that's
really what you believe
well this is this is pure paganism it
really is
uh and it goes to show that
the the religiosity is a real need
that we have it's ingrained in us as
human beings
and so if you reject uh
christianity if as nancy pelosi has
rejected her supposed catholic faith
uh she goes to paganism as many
democrats have and are now essentially
mother earth gaia worshipers but
remember always remember this is the
pro-science side
yes pro-science people who believe that
men can get pregnant
women have penises babies aren't people
and mother earth makes fires when she's
angry at us for driving suvs
pure unadulterated science
number four the new york post has an
interesting article looking quote inside
the privileged lives of protesters
busted for rioting in manhattan and
here's a look at the subjects of the
articles you can see the mug shots here
a little rough let's be honest not the
best angle on these guys it's a it's a
mug shot you can't blame them
it but you know if i was a privileged
rioter i would have a personal stylist
with me at all times so that when i get
arrested maybe they can come in and just
do a little
little touch-up just run over you know
fix me up a little bit
i mean your mug shot it's a big moment
it's gonna be with you for the rest of
your life anytime somebody googles you
that's going to pop up so it's going to
be there forever
they should really give you a chance to
comb your hair i think put on some
makeup
whether you're a girl or guy no judgment
here no discrimination
that one guy there uh the one one over
from the top on the left
he appears to have some sort of dead or
perhaps hibernating
um animal uh some kind of woodland
creature on top of his head he should
have been allowed to take that off in my
opinion
so but anyway here's here let's go to
the article uh it says
the so-called revolutionaries who were
busted for rioting at a new african
black panther party rally
took a break from their yacht club lives
and modeling careers to be a part of the
mayhem
yes these are members of the black
panther party
apparently they certainly don't make
black panthers the way they they used to
as all i could say
the seven comrades including wealthy
upper state eastsider clara crabber
had the mugshots tweeted out by the nypd
early wednesday
days after their arrests they were
cuffed during a protest organized by the
panthers and the revolutionary
abolitionist movement
uh groups condemning the death of daniel
prude who was killed while in custody
of the rochester police department in
march aside from crabber the redhead
daughter of an architect and child
psychiatrist with a second home in
connecticut
five of the others arrested appear to
also come from privileged backgrounds
um frank furmeister okay wait
clara crabber and frank furmeister
all right those are really are the
police sure that these are their real
names and not not uh
not fake names that sounds like the kind
of name you would just make up on the
spot if the cops are asking you
what's my name uh it's uh frank fur
meister smith frank fermi no
frank furmeister actually is a frederick
firma i mean frank furmeister
uh fermi yeah that's my name anyway it
says that frank furmeister charged with
uh
rioting and possession of a graffiti
instrument is a freelance art director
who's designed ads for joe coffee and
has also worked for pepsi samsung and
the glenn levitt
he studied fine arts with a
concentration in photography at florida
state college
uh blah blah blah blah okay so you get
the idea these are all a bunch of
privileged brats
no big surprise there this really this
goes back to the point i made uh before
about these protests that
they are expressions of extreme
decadence more than anything else these
are privileged
privileged comfortable people uh
searching for a struggle searching for
a form of suffering um an oppression to
make their lives meaningful
we just as people we we it's very
difficult for us to
simply be comfortable and live in luxury
and admit that that's our lives
you'd think it'd be easy but it's not we
we need to have some sort of struggle
something to overcome
and i think there are so many people in
our country who live lives of
such unending comfort and all of us in
fact
every single one of us no matter what
our socioeconomic situation is we all
are or almost all of us are absurdly
comfortable
in comparison to almost everyone else
who has ever lived
on planet earth uh that's just a
reflection of of modern society and
because of that you've got a lot of
people who are desperate to
you know find meaning and some sort of
struggle to invent some kind of
you know boogeyman for them to fight
against and i think that's
a lot of what we're seeing with these
writings the riots and the looting and
antifa and everything else number five
finally in our most important story
today as you know i have always been a
critic of dogs
i think dogs generally take take more
than they give they are needy emotional
high maintenance it's like having a
teenager in the home i guess except one
that craps on the carpet and eats your
couch
but there are a few good dogs out there
even i must admit
and here's one right here watch the
police
oh
[Music]
i mean look on the bright side at least
he wasn't facing the other direction
that would have been
things can always be worse i guess is
what we learned from that
but that dog right there is a dog who
makes himself useful
um so many dogs are called good dogs
though they have not earned the title
that dog though
that's a good dog good dog well done
well done thank you for your service
let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation i'll be
canceling all the people freaking out
over the chiefs fans last night
uh booing the players as they had their
moment of unity
so backing up here for a moment the nfl
was was back in action on thursday night
not a very interesting game chiefs won
34-20 of course the question was
what would happen before the game you
know how far would the nfl go in the
first game back to alienate the fan base
even further
i thought at the very least they might
randomly select a white fan from the
stands and drag them onto the field to
be ritualistically flogged as atonement
for the myriad sins of whiteness
but shockingly that didn't happen uh
there was none of that
there wasn't much of anything the texans
didn't come out for the anthem at all
which
fine i'd prefer that i prefer that over
the theatrics during the anthem
just get it out of sight as far as i'm
concerned uh the chiefs all
all stood but one player so that wasn't
too bad
but then right before the game started
they went out
onto the field locked arms and had a
moment of unity
and the fans didn't seem to like it very
much listen
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
now the left and the in the people in
sports media but i repeat myself i
suppose
have been fainting quite performatively
over this they boot a moment of unity
why i never um that's how i imagine them
when they're tweeting doing this with
their hands how dare these
you know how dare these fans boo racial
unity they must be a bunch of racists
how could they
a headline on the the leftist news site
raw story called the fans classless
trash
john fuglesang said america's racist
always booing at demonstrations against
the racism
never booing at actual racism
sportswriter michael lee was
uh was was very upset he said my
hometown's got no love for unity they're
booing unity now
charlotte climber of the extremist group
the human rights campaign said
who's surprised by these fans who are
booing it was never about the national
anthem it was never about respect for
the flag it was always about sheer
discomfort over any personal
accountability a fan might be motivated
to consider
regarding their role in systemic racism
another media person
cameron justice said booing equality is
pretty telling
and on and on and on now all of this of
course misses the point
on purpose despite the pretensions of
the left
nobody is against unity or justice or
equality
the left likes to pretend that it's
waging a war against cartoon villains
who are
in principle actually opposed to you
know things like justice as if we're
saying
yeah you know we're not big fans of
justice just uh it doesn't do much for
us we're
we're sort of anti-justice we're big
fans of injustice actually we're
injustice that's more our speed now
that's not a position that anybody holds
even people who actually do favor
injustice like the people who defend
rioters and looters as they burn down
city blocks
those are people who favor injustice but
they don't see themselves that way they
would never be that explicit about it in
fact
they feel the need to claim that rioting
and looting
is justice and to defend it on that
basis that's how humans work it's called
rationalizing
so why were people booing
well the reason people booed the moment
of unity is that
we have come to understand what is
really meant in our culture
by unity it's just like when someone
starts talking about being
anti-racist i'd boo that too is that
because i'm pro-racist
no it's because when i hear someone talk
about being anti-racist
i know that they don't really mean
anti-racist i know that anti-racism is a
euphemism
and a lot of a lot of actual racism is
promoted and justified under the guise
of being
anti-racist so yes i boo you when you
say it because
i know what you really mean and you know
what you really mean
so let's stop pretending we don't
understand each other
this is the way the game is always
played though with the left they do the
same thing with black lives matter
if somebody opposes black lives matter
they say oh you don't think black lives
matter huh
no i do think black lives matter
everybody thinks that nearly everyone in
the country agrees on that point
near unanimous agreement but you keep
saying it anyway why is that because
behind that slogan is a whole bunch of
other stuff
that has nothing to do with with black
people at all and all i need to do is
check out the black lives matter website
look at their professional beliefs
uh their their agenda as they lay it out
themselves
to confirm that this has nothing to do
with black people at all
and there are dozens of examples of this
pro-choice oh you don't believe in
choice do you no i do
i think freedom of choice is good but i
also think that killing innocent people
is bad and when you talk about choice i
know
that's what you actually mean and so
that's why i boo
your pro-choice slogans because i know
that they are really pro-murder
so going back to the racial unity bit i
believe in racial unity
i would love to have racial unity i
would love to have all kinds of unity in
this country
but is that really what you want on the
left is that what you mean when you talk
about it
do you mean that we will all be unified
on an equal playing field and that will
we will live our lives and treat each
other as human beings without
segregation without any need for anyone
to apologize for their race or
to profess feelings of guilt or to take
a submissive or groveling stance
that the law will treat everyone the
same and everybody's held to the same
standard and so on
is that what you mean it isn't is it
well then you don't really want racial
unity you want something else
and it's that something else that was
booed
and deserves to be booed now personally
the players locking arms and and
standing there doesn't bother me any
doesn't offend me
if i was in the stands i probably
wouldn't boot it and i i can
as far as the nfl players themselves go
i could i could very well believe that
that many of them if not most of them
really had great intentions and
and as far as they're concerned they
really were standing for unity was kind
of an empty gesture but whatever
uh basically harmless
yet um the
the fans in the stands and so many other
people
they are jaded and cynical when it comes
to these kinds of gestures and
statements
and for highly justified reasons
because they see how in our culture the
left takes
these concepts and ideas that
by definition in reality are good
the left takes them empties them out
turns them into euphemisms that stand
for things that have nothing really to
do with those words at all
and that's what the booing was about um
so and that's why if you're complaining
about the booing you're canceled
okay we'll leave it there that's that's
it for today um hope you have a great
weekend
pray for our country god bless america
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there